Quality, resilience and stability,...
...Japan aims to achieve these three goals together with Africa...
...through various activities.
Building infrastructure that meets local needs...
...and spreading "kaizen," the Japanese philosophy and production method...
...for increased productivity.
Combating infectious diseases like ebola,...
...saving countless lives and promoting universal health coverage.
Supporting a stable, clean water supply...
...and implementing human resource development for millions of people.
Our focus is to improve quality and provide empowerment.
Believing in the potential that the future holds,...
...Japan will work hand in hand with Africa.